take a simple thought how could we ever
get a player of this magnitude on our
team
we've been drafted you know in the low
20s and the you know
30s or something forever and and that
pick has never allowed us
that kind of opportunity uh john did an
incredible job
and i think this is another statement
for joan snyder man he has done such a
remarkable job for so many years
the husband go for it and he did it
again and uh i'm just
we're all fired up about it looking
forward to benjamin coming to our club
you know for us um you know i certainly
don't feel like this is a precedent
for a player to shoot his way out of
town i feel like we had a great
contingency plan
for any situation it just so happened
that the situation worked out the way it
did
but um no i'm not i'm not concerned
about that precedent
the first voice was pete carroll coach
of the seahawks second voice joe douglas
gm of the jets and look i agree with joe
douglas's take there
if you give jamal adams away for a
fourth round pick
then he has shot his way out of town as
douglas phrased it
when you get two first round picks a
third round pick
and bradley macdougald for jamal adams
and a fourth round pick in 2022
you can't say no to that we talked about
that yesterday this is not
hey jamal we just surrender here go
leave get out of here
it's we got an offer that we have to
take because we got a guy who doesn't
want to be here
we'll gladly take the compensation and
move forward yeah no no exactly right i
mean it was
it's a win-win situation i mean really i
think both guys explained it perfectly
you know the jets hey yeah they they
traded away their best player
okay there was a situation there he
wants big money
he was disgruntled he didn't want to be
there well it didn't hurt the dr
the draft price and you know again let's
just make sure we make this clear
you know the jets aren't one player away
they're they're not like i'm not going
in the season going like oh
man if they just kept jamal adams they
might have gone to the super bowl like
come on
you know it's it's everybody especially
up here in the new york new york area
which jamal adams
everyone says he's a clown and oh he's
got a big mouth blah blah blah he talks
crap about adam gase and then everybody
goes look it
he's right you know and everyone jumps
on adam gays so he caused a crap storm
here for the jets and some of their
players in the organization
but joe douglas did a great job and
getting great value for jamal adams
and jamal adams got what he wanted he's
an awesome football player and he went
to a team that really fits
his style i think on and off the field
and it should work i think we'll see
yeah and joe douglas also said yesterday
they're not punting on the 2020 season
and
and i agree with him because look you
had
a storm brewing with jamal adams
with the article that came out on friday
where he took aim at the head coach
just a few days before it's time to show
up and try to get everyone on the same
page it was going to be a huge
distraction it was going to be a huge
problem
was jamal adams going to act like jalen
ramsey and hold himself out of practices
and games
because he claimed to be injured was he
going to openly disrespect adam gase
what was he going to do next in his
effort to get out of town
now you've turned the page on that with
sufficient compensation and a guy who
replaces him now
bradley mcdougall isn't jamal adams
chris but tell me what you think
of bradley mcdougall as a guy who steps
in to the job that jamal adams had well
he's a really solid
nfl starting safety you know a guy that
can be a strong safety or free safety
can do a little bit of both but he's a
fearless tackler i mean he throws his
body around like a
like a crazy man okay so you know i look
at it from that standpoint certainly not
the talent jamal adams is but
you know this is without without
question one of the 32 best in the game
so you know that that they got a guy
that they're going to be able to depend
on and certainly
you know fill that position fill it to
the position
of the way jamal adams is will they be
able to do all the creative things
around
you know him that they did around jamal
adams no they're not he's not that
guy but you're not going to look at him
and go oh
you know they got felice there look he's
the weak part of our defense no he will
not be that he's good in pass he's good
and run
like i said he is a legitimate nfl
starting safety
yeah and and uh you if there isn't a
huge drop there's a drop but if it's not
a dramatic drop
and you've picked up two first round
picks and a third round pick and you
gave up a fourth round pick
next year to get that third round pick
to you know they always they always have
that
i feel like they just want to prove to
everyone that they're being very careful
and they're being very meticulous we got
to get the balance just right well the
two first round picks is fine but we
need to i need a three and i'll give you
a four like you know we just got to get
it just right but you look at the whole
package
it's a great deal for the jets it
eliminates a major problem
and we'll see what bradley mcdougall can
do paired up with marcus may
in the secondary and and you're right
they're not one player away
they weren't going to be a super bowl
contender this year with jamal adams
they're not going to be a super bowl
contender without jamal adams for
starters they just need to build on how
they finish last season six and two
and try to be a playoff contender and
then build on that
into 2021. i know every coach and every
player and every gm and every owner says
we're trying to win the super bowl
because
you got to make the fans believe that so
they show up for the games this year
that doesn't really matter
but it's okay to have more realistic
objectives and i think for the jets the
realistic objective is to just be in the
hunt
for a playoff berth and maybe get one of
those seven spots in the afc
yeah that's exactly right or just
show you know improvement in the
football team as far as the way it looks
being competitive whoa sam darnold took
that next step
that question's out of our mind we know
he's the franchise now
i think if they can just give positive
vibes there and like like
jets nation let's be realistic here and
you know i know
adam gates seems to be some easy guy to
jump on i know he had the googly eyes
during the press conference and all that
but
you know again i'll stand strong i think
he's a better coach than people are
giving him credit for
i mean it wasn't like a team of
all-stars down there in the dolphins and
they were competitive every year and
went to the playoffs
with a bunch of guys that i think if we
sat here right now we'd go damn i can
only name like two or three guys off the
top of my head
on the team so you know let's give it a
chance to develop i like what i've seen
from joe douglas i still am a believer
in adam gase like i said and they just
they need to show it on the field this
year
sam darnold can't get hurt he can't get
mono they need to have a complete season
where they show
true growth as an organization and
hopefully that happens
yeah i doubt that he's going to get mono
again no that would be one hell of a
coincidence
but uh but yeah having your starting
quarterback gone
after just a game or two for several
weeks because he has mono
that tends to put a dark cloud over the
season but they and
it was a crippling start to the season
last year from a schedule standpoint
you saw that coming and they went one in
seven right and then they turned it
around and went six and two down the
stretch
and the fact that they didn't just throw
in the towel and tank
i there's there's reason to believe that
they can be
competitive not super bowl caliber but
competitive and lay the foundation for
something that could flourish
in 2021 if they're patient and if if
some things go their way
and if they make the most out of the two
first-round picks they're gonna have in
2021 their own
plus seattle's all right uh bradley
mcdougall trying to help make the team
into a super bowl contender right away
he took to social media to try to get
jadavian clowney to sign with the jets
now look it's one thing for mcdougall to
want clowney
the jets have to want to pay him they
have to believe in him but he's still
available
he's eventually going to sign with
somebody and uh how would you feel about
the jets as a contender if all of a
sudden
it came out that they had managed to
land janavian clown well
it you know you know let's not forget
this defense was damn good last year
you know that that's the one thing i
think we've kind of lost on the shovel
like greg williams he coached the top 10
defense in football last year
and did a phenomenal job with without a
lot of like household names
you get a guy like gideon clowney we
know this is the master of f the play
up right there in the nfl right now now
i have a hard time believing that
jodevion clowney
just from everything we've heard it
sounds like he wants to be a part of a
team that
can compete and contend right now and
from that standpoint that's where i go
that i don't know
makes sense you know i don't know i know
my heart of hearts i feel like
with seattle clearing a little space and
everything like that that it's going to
end up there i don't know that i'm just
just taking a shot in the dark but yeah
certainly would make me look at them a
little different and go oh
okay maybe i thought the best they could
do was
you know seven and nine and now you get
a gideon clownie all right maybe they
could be a pain in the butt be eight and
eight nine and seven i don't know
something like that but
not gonna like rearrange or change my my
total thoughts of their team
hey with all these patriots opting out
the the the vacuum well
top of the division that's what's crazy
right it's a little more intriguing
right maybe maybe if you are the jets
you think you know
well but maybe the you know the patriot
these guys are
conscientiously choosing to walk away in
new england there's an opportunity there
and if we added jadabi and clowny uh
maybe we can compete
with the bills and maybe we can end up
winning the division i
look it's it's it's not an easy call to
make when you are a team that clearly
isn't in that super bowl window and you
have to convince a guy who's looking for
a super bowl window
to join your team but uh you know at
this point i think clowney just wants to
be wanted
and it doesn't feel like there's anyone
that really wants him at this point in
large part because you still can't
determine whether or not he's completely
healthy
and it's hard to value a guy that is
going to show up in
spurts but may not be able to show up
for the full season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports